I'm back for a bit.
All of my meetings for the day have been
concluded.
Realistically,
could probably have squeezed in like a
couple more hours of streaming a day,
but this cut is driving me crazy and
everything moves super slow.
pull up reream. We're going to talk
about what we're doing here.
Now, Windows decided to reboot my PC
because Windows
uh Why is the puffer down here?
Fine.
Okay.
So,
we can do
So, we have our plot interface up
and we get to start on some new things
now.
I've had a lot going on today.
So, uh, take the first few minutes here
and kind of just think through what I
want to do on this.
Right now, we have
we got seed sensitivity.
We started on hyper pram sensitivity and
then something weird happened, right?
one E minus one
late hyper pram
really.
Well, they shouldn't be getting
averaged, right?
Something
you know about arc prize. I know it
exists. Not super applicable to what I'm
doing though.
Really not uh not super applicable, you
know?
Oh, you know what I meant to do? Hang on
before I forget because it is Friday.
I meant to reply to a couple of friends
cuz I'm almost done I think in the Bay
Area.
One, two. Oh, yeah. And then there was
one more I needed to send. Then we will
be good to start.
I just typed, "Hey, h a Y.
I've not been sleeping too well the last
few days."
There we go.
So,
why did all these trials do this?
Why are they all like this?
No CUDA GPU is lovely. I reboot the
container.
Welcome YouTube folks.
Just going to do few hours
casual work on uh
the new science.
All right,
let's see if this actually does anything
now.
I mean, presumably some of these runs
should work, right? I'm literally just
sweeping learning rate.
If not, then something's off.
We'll figure it out.
H.
I load hyper prams completely wrong.
If I just do this, it works, doesn't it?
Am I dumb?
Uh, is it that sensitive?
Really?
Oh, well that's why.
Oops.
Why is that how log base works?
Dumb
your chat off or something. We're good.
Have it covered.
Linda log.
I'm typing totally wrong.
Here we are.
Ah, so is it ge? It's beyond space.
Right.
Not bad.
Not too bad.
Hello, Western.
Welcome.
Oh jeez. I've watched you code. Very
little ranting. Have you watched my guy?
Research gets me mad.
Research makes me mad. Engineering
generally pretty chill.
Yeah, I need to actually
a bit of stuff I need to do here, right?
This is fine, right? Then we just do
draw
plot line.
Way better, right?
I do score.
There we go.
Look at that.
Now we have our sensitivity. Of course,
we got to scale this and clean this up
and stuff, but we're going to get all
sorts of different types of graphs out
of this
one for the email.
Okay.
People have been doing all sorts of cool
stuff in the uh the Discord lately.
I saw Yeah, somebody had overcooked.
This poor soul uh
thing.
Be good.
Okay.
Did you run the same value in average?
What is the funny graph? Well, the axis
are totally mislabeled, but this is the
learning rate and this is the
performance on Pong. So this is the
stable learning rate range where pong
solves. And then you can see this is
uh this is too high or whatever.
Are you making my I'm not doing like I'm
not trying to replace wombi. I'm trying
to do something different. That's like
not what that would be.
What are the new frontiers, Mr. Joseph?
It's a play on words. We're doing
scaling laws and parto frontier
analysis. And generally, we're going to
do the highest quality science and
reinforcement learning.
What's the next project?
Proper compute data trade-off analysis
scaling laws. The works
This is just a math thing I don't know.
Like of all the different areas of math,
stats is by far my weakest. So I know
like nothing.
Does anybody know this? Actually, some
of my viewers should at least have some
understanding of some math, right?
This seems bad. This answer seems bad to
me
having to fit a model to this. I mean, I
could just use the most adjacent points,
right?
Could I not just do that?
He's learning. All right. He's uh he
actually does give a [ __ ] about doing
the like doing RL stuff. He's thrown
together a few interesting things.
He's well known and he's done a very
good job of like popularizing quite a
few uh areas of tech, right?
He's not an RL guy, right? He's new to
this stuff.
He's kind of a generalist.
filter is. I'm going to be honest with
you.
I could write a cowman filter for you
10 or 12 years ago. I don't even like
other than it being a smoothing filter,
I don't remotely remember what the
hellman filter is.
There are a lot of basics like this
honestly.
Really like the only thing that matters
is if you are like a specialist then you
should know the actual practical
like day-to-day
toolkit that actually gets stuff done
within your specialty.
Like I literally failed an interview one
time um where I
What the hell was it? I forgot. Oh yeah,
literally I couldn't I couldn't tell you
what sine of x squar looked like because
I just like I have not thought about the
shapes of functions even though that's
super basic in 15 years.
I don't know if I think about it for
long enough. Okay. Yeah, it's a stretch
on the x axis. yada yada y
know otherwise
really the only good judge of um
if somebody is capable is the final
product of what they're able to
accomplish, right?
It's the only
good judge.
I just do the same value. Is that what I
do?
Does anybody have a good solution to
this?
Like if I instead of sampling the same
point, I sample
if I want one sample for 50 different
learning rates instead of um five
samples for 10 different learning rates.
Can you still get a 95% confidence
interval easily or no?
like 20 runs.
That's actually cleaner if I do it this
way, isn't it?
I think it's slightly better if we do it
the other way, right?
Like if we do it this way.
This is slightly better because then the
seeds will be adjacent. So we can
probably like compute easier.
Yeah, this is fun. All right, we'll go
from this.
Really, the only goal I have for today
is to get a few of these different plots
going.
you know, we start having our uh
building the basis of our analysis
toolkit just a little bit, you know,
nothing super fancy.
Hey, FBR, I'm working on uh some of the
new science stuff today. It's going to
be on uh hyperparameter sensitivity
going to be the new thing I'm going to
do.
YouTube is a minute behind. Lovely.
That's YouTube for you.
I got buffer working with C++ bullet 400
SPS. You were right. Of course I was.
But other robotics have one environment
and lots of agents. Yes, but there's no
reason that should be the case. That is
because the engine is stupid. Literally
no other reason.
Aha, look at this.
Yes.
Very good.
Uh, there should be some variance here,
shouldn't there?
Oh, it's like almost Okay, there's like
no variance there. That's cool. The
middle there's like a fair bit of seed
variance here, but all is solve.
That's cool.
Oh man, I am so tired. But it's like
I've had I literally
I like borderline poisoned myself with
the amount of coffee I had in SF
yesterday. So I'm trying to not go nuts
today.
The last two times I've gone to SF to
get through all the meetings, I've ended
up having like five or six coffees and
coming home with a migraine.
Like literally like nauseous and dizzy,
stumbling to dinner.
Okay, that's actually at least
reasonable.
Wait, is it that per core? Is that
across all cores?
Cuz if it's that per core, like we can
work with That
Oh, then that's actually usable.
Then on like a 16 core, you should be
able to get a million step per second
training pretty much.
name skip as one.
So frame skip
there's it's not exactly the same when
you're doing physics, right?
Because you don't have to
the only thing that matters is the
number of solver steps you need to make
it stable.
Did I do this right?
According to this I did. Oh, you know
what it is?
It gets decayed. Damn it.
We'll let this run. Let me use a
restroom real quick.
Okay,
YouTube folks.
Oh,
something's wonky here, right?
Well,
well,
then I have local thingy in here.
Thought I had local.
Maybe not.
No, I didn't. Okay.
Well, I know the super easy way to do
this, right?
One fun thing I found out. So, I finally
bothered to replace the batteries in my
scale.
And uh I said I was losing about three
pounds a week was my estimate. And lo
and behold, I was spot on.
Exactly.
Turns out
like
conservation of energy is not rocket
science.
This is an MIT professor I like who
would always say uh
oh it's actually we shouldn't say it's
not rocket science. Rocket science is
pretty easy. Neuroscience is hard. We
should say it's not neuroscience.
Well, I'm being a little bit flippant,
convert,
but like, yeah, it turns out that
uh,000
to,500 calorie deficit per day
equals one pound lost every two to three
days. Equals three pound per week equals
15 pound in five weeks.
What is your preferred way to handle
rewards?
in end of code. It depends, right? If
you have
if it's like if you're going to
increment the value of zero to the new
one, like the only reason to do this is
if you have multiple sources of changing
the reward, right?
You have multiple sources to change the
reward or not. Oops.
There we go. Look at that.
That be
Isn't this crazy?
Learning rate pretty stable.
This is what we're going to be calling a
stable range of a hyperparameter here.
It's actually funny that it kind of
reloads some of it
at the optimal. We're going to do a lot
of stuff like this. Don't worry.
That's almost an order of magnitude
where any learning rate you give it
solves the environment consistently.
Um it's not so much that this is a
stable range. So the implication here is
that anything in this range is good.
Yeah. Well, we're going to have this
stuff. Don't worry.
What other types of things did I want? I
wanted compute v data.
I have like a good compute P data.
I think that's harder.
Yeah. So, I think
we kind of need to clean this up.
we can probably do several M's on the
same axis.
Let's just clean this up then so I can
do um
I'm actually curious. How the heck does
this guy have a million experiments?
It's still a lot of experiments, but
Okay.
Oops.
More to destroy the puffer than meets
the eye.
There is, but it has nothing to do with
world models and topology.
Don't worry, he's just a friendly puffer
companion.
Don't worry about it.
I'm trying to think what I want to do
with this from here.
I kind of need a better way to do logs.
Well, wait a second.
Can I just
I'm being stupid, right?
No, I'm not really being stupid. I'm
mostly just being tired to be honest.
There's a restroom real quick while this
runs. We're going to get multiple M's on
the same plot. It'll be cool.
SIMD EX2. Yep, that makes sense. I
haven't even touched MD. Right.
Weston, using SIMD is not an idea. It's
obvious. It's just no, we haven't
bothered because most of our M's are so
fast. It doesn't uh it's not required.
Yeah. I wonder if if uh Rayson
replied to me
and he didn't.
I uh commented on one of his post. He
was like posting about donations to Rayb
and I asked him how much it would be to
have a puffer banner. Yeah.
Apparently, the guy really only wants um
he wants to have like 1,800 a month or
whatever on the project, which is like
I can give him a chunk of that at least
for Puffer be a little bigger. We can
sponsor the heck out of it.
A lib is awesome.
Such a good library.
20 mil SPS. You actually can get uh
Cartpole actually runs more than 20 mil
SPS already is the thing. It doesn't
train 20 million unless you go to stupid
big batches or really silly networks.
You can actually get it training at 20
million though. I've done it for the
hell of it as a joke. We have gotten
cart pull 20 mil.
Oh.
You joke about speeds that I make a
reality.
I wish I weren't so tired though. Couple
weeks we're done. One week left on the
cut.
I said I said to myself I was going to
do six weeks. So, I'm going to make it
through six weeks. Holy is brutal.
should be working on this in the
meantime, right?
to wait forever for
What do you mean only 3k stars?
You know what that is? You know how
proud I am of this?
We uh I believe we're a little bit
above. Yeah, now we're above this.
Right. So we passed the literal meta
branded actively developed RL library
with like that brand behind it,
right? With all like the stupid
enterprise things attached to it as
well.
So
not bad.
Yeah. Yeah. No, I know what you mean.
But like the thing is 3K for RL is
incredibly incredibly successful.
That's like a breakthrough success. I'm
very very proud of it. And yeah, of
course it's going to get bigger,
Honestly, that's like the easiest part
of it.
Like, I kind of want French toast and a
hamburger,
but uh that's the easiest part of it.
The hardest part of this stuff is
freaking
keeping myself awake to work and then
doing my freaking 10K in the morning on
this.
But hey, I kind of timed it so that um
the like hard end bit of this would be
kind of in between blocks of uh
projects. Anyways, I honestly I didn't
expect to have like a new super concrete
and valuable project idea in like less
than two weeks after I finished my
previous block of work. I guess I kind
of turned it around quick this time.
I'm kind of considering anything I get
done on this like this week and next
week to kind of just be a, you know,
bonus head start.
There will be an article on all this the
uh personal fitness stuff I've been
doing.
I think it'll help some people.
pretty much the only other thing
I do
lately while I've been in uh in Palo
Alto, aside from like the business calls
and stuff, the schedule's pretty much
been like get up, run, lift, work on
this stuff, and then uh I like take
myself over to just a casual local place
I always go to. I like listen to my
audio book.
That's pretty much my day.
Funny enough, this is still because
inevitably being in California, I end up
with more in-person stuff than I would
end up with not while I'm here. Um,
it's still kind of noisy.
All right. Yay. Done. You see this?
We're done. It ran.
See, first this is you're going to do
the pong one, right?
Yeah. Pong.
Dude, what is wrong with my freaking
editor? Why is it doing this?
Stop it.
Never does this.
SSH ought to be fine.
Ooh,
nifty, huh?
Nifty.
All we have to do is we swap this with
perf and score.
Well, I like just information being
clear, right,
post boast a lot about puffer in the
code bullet community. Sadly, only a
small amount to actually care about.
Don't really know any more I could do at
my level.
Yeah. I mean, honestly, the best thing
for you, man, is if you're interested in
this stuff is just keep building things,
right?
I was like 16 when I first started doing
research and maybe like 18 when I first
started doing passively decent research.
Hey there. Keep grinding guys.
I am trying
I'm like so hungry and tired it's
difficult to work.
I'm going to just get a few simple
things done today while I'm doing this
stuff.
Yeah, that whole thing is a mess, man.
That's really messed
I don't know what to tell you. It's like
the hours maybe improve a little bit.
No, actually they get even later for
you.
Uh
when I'm in the East Coast because it's
three hours later. I guess maybe you
catch morning streams then
ending.
It'll probably be a little easier to do
slightly
longer hours on that. The next
exercise block once I'm done with this
cut is going to be less cardio. Cardio
is what takes for freaking ever and more
just like general bodybuilding and
strength style work.
Trying to get my weight back on, but
lean this time.
the objective.
dude. It's my schedule's really not that
hardcore.
Yeah, this it's not this I've done this
before. Like legitimately I've done this
before.
Like nobody does this for months or
years on end.
No idea what that that mess is.
UK.
Insufficient.
Insufficient bullets per eagle.
Nesian North Africa.
Holy
messed this up somehow.
It must have right.
All right. So, this is why we're using
this thing.
Now, we got both graphs. Yeah.
are nice
couple nice graphs. Yeah,
I'm trying to think. I definitely am not
going to keep doing this until six. I'm
exhausted. So, I'm going to see how much
longer I can do a little bit of
productive stuff on it, though.
I'd like to just do this all day
tomorrow fresh.
Oh, well this is messed up, right? is
not learning right.
We just have a couple M's.
I guess we'll just spend a bit of time
making the plots look a little nicer
realistically, if I do this well, we can
just queue up a lot of these different
groups of runs.
And um we could generate like tons and
tons and tons of data here for analysis.
All right. Who wants to help me make
these things actually Ready?
eventually I might end up even being
able to put this I can probably end up
actually putting this on the uh the
website, right?
This is nice. Right
there we are.
This actually not working. That's super
weird, right?
It's actually like worse than before.
Now it's just like fully just scales.
what's a good res aspect ratio for
plots?
this can't possibly be right, can it?
No. Cuz I'm on a 1440p monitor, aren't
I?
This is
Yeah. And this is more than half my
screen.
Yeah, this should fit. Something is
wrong here.
Why is this this much of the screen
size?
I mean, what is my resolution set?
Weird.
If I do it this way, then it's correct,
right?
Yeah. But then the scales typically
going to affect the uh the resolution as
well, right? Like this is the actual
size
that's going to start affecting the
resolution. If I go smaller.
This it it's like 12. Yeah. Okay. I have
it wrong. It was 1440.
It should be 1280.
Why it looks weird.
Okay. So, now that we have these plots,
right? And then if we do it like this,
now it's actually good.
No, I'm not doing it in rail, man.
It's just uh plot late.
But I mean, check this out, right? We're
like, I don't know less than a day total
work of sleepy work like sleepy building
stuff.
We have sensitivity of specific
hyperparameters.
We've got sensitivity to seed.
Big mistake,
dude. I don't want to have to do
like there's no way you get that into a
browser in a dev loop that doesn't suck.
I would have to do like a full from
scratch xforwarded thing where I'd have
to like process
I'd have to like process structured data
in C for all the different logs.
That would just be a massive pain. Look,
maybe I will do that, but let me at
least get the damn project done first.
If I if I get good enough results that I
think it's worth porting to a snazzy
like local tool or something, I'll do
that. But for now, it's like give me a
break
sensitive parameters.
Uh, the breakout one's a little bit
surprising, I suppose.
Maybe get somebody to get me a good
color palette of rafts.
all of these by a ton.
Eight.
Yeah, I'm kind of just super sleepy
doing this. I had some meetings and now
I'm like starving, man. I want French
toast and a hamburger, but one week left
uncut.
The heck did I do? Why does this not
work?
Why is this stupid thing not
not work right?
Am I crazy?
Go to sleep. It's 5:00 p.m.
I'm going to go to dinner soon.
Quick summary. There've been short
streams. The summary is this thing,
right?
We've got now uh hyperparameter
ablations that we can do.
We can get sensitivity over a specific
hyperparameter for different runs. We
can get training curve sensitivity to
seeds. And we're going to come up with
like several more things like this.
Evaluate tons of different parameters,
tons of different M's. We're going to
make this whole thing like super quick
and automatic. And um we're really going
to ideally discover
like a lot of the ways that these
parameters behave across environments,
across scales.
You're not the first one to suggest
that.
Is it this thing somehow?
Don't see how it would be, but we'll try
it.
We actually do have a couple M's that
have that stuff done with them.
Oh, there you go.
Why? I don't know why the heck it does
that. Oh, no. I actually I totally know
why it does that. That's fine. Silly me.
Live episode reward for one of the M's.
Yeah, we have a few different things.
There's a finance N for that. Actually,
we have permission to release. I just
haven't gotten around to it yet.
This will do though, right?
Can somebody tell me why the y axis is
gone?
Like completely gone.
I mean, I could go down way more of a
rabbit hole than this with it, right?
The reason I'm doing this is because we
have specific types of visuals here and
like a stupid web tool is not the right
thing for this.
The web tool is not the right thing for
this because basically like
imagine we're going to do an ablation
with say 30 experiments on every
hyperparameter for every envven puffer
and we're going to collect these onto
separate like different plots and like
display them in different groups
with like normalized coordinates.
We're going to do the same thing for
like a ton of different types of
studies.
Which of these is like a stable
the connect four or something?
Connect four is pretty straightforward
to do this for, right?
I wouldn't use a JavaScript based
library at the very least. JavaScript
bale works with VR. What chance of an
end?
You could and it sounds really cool, but
when you try it, you find out it's
actually not.
I'd literally rather write C than
JavaScript. That's how much I hate
JavaScript.
The thing I really like about this is I
don't even have to copy like I don't
even have to deal with copying the
results of these experiments to my local
box or anything.
We're only like 200 lines of plotting
code on this.
and if I had three times the amount of
energy I have, I do all sorts of crazy
things. But now I kind of pick the crazy
thing that I think is the most likely to
push the project forward.
Like you have to give yourself room to
explore obviously
and that's kind of part of what this is,
but I'm also exploring like what is the
thing that I can explore that I think is
the most likely like the highest EV
Okay.
What is this?
Still running.
I just wanted like one more beta point
so I can see my graphs a little better.
But it's kind of cool that it's
incremental like this, right? So imagine
that I like ceue up each of these things
as a different uh a different type of
like different experiment or whatever.
And
like I get the results of these things
back
and I just like keep dumping them into a
folder and I'll have it all like picked
up automatically.
This is pretty much all I wanted to do
for today.
So, I have it set up.
I think you're going to see the
difference like once I have this thing
fully ready.
Like
how many experiments is this going to
even be?
Let's say I do like 30 per
hyperparameter,
n hyperparameters, 300 per n,000
This is probably going to be somewhere
between like 20 and 60,000 experiments,
Book. Nah,
don't need to do that.
If the data processing becomes a
bottleneck, I'll fix that. It really
shouldn't be, though.
I guess you're kind of right that if you
try to load tens of thousands of
experiments up, that probably breaks.
Don't worry about it. I'll deal with it.
Wouldn't break if I used actually.
Just be fast.
Speed sensitivity on this thing's really
nice.
as you see things. Yeah, I'm just going
to do that in the code here though.
So basically it's not like these plots
are it's not like it has to regenerate
all the data every time I do these plots
right like the idea is that I have uh a
group of runs that is collectively going
to be a line or like a point whatever it
is going to be for this group of
experiments. Then each group of
experiments gets run and saved to its
own data file. And then the plotting
software just loads up all the current
data files.
It's not just going to be everything
under experiments like that. That's what
you can already do with Neptune. This is
going to be quite different. I have
pretty good ideas of what I want to run
already as well.
I just need like uh some food and a
decent night's sleep.
But hey, it's 5:30 on Friday. I'm
starving.
Um, so I'm going to just go get dinner
and
got dinner.
I'm going to go get some dinner and I'll
probably be hanging around later. We'll
see. Or I might just take some time to
just chill for the night. We'll see. I'm
going try to get myself some good sleep,
though. And then the plan is for pretty
much all day tomorrow to be uh to be
doing this
and to be doing this with like actual
energy. And we should actually I think
we should be able to build
either the entire job system to handle
all of this stuff
or all of the visualization like loading
and stuff for this. Possibly both.
We will see.
But anyways, for the folks who've been
tuning in,
thank you for your interest.
Uh, I stream all my research.
I am right here on X. I have lots of
articles including educational material
for newcomers and some of my research
reports as well. Puffer.ai for all the
things. Start the GitHub if you want to
help me out for free. Really helps a
ton. Join the Discord to get involved.
And we got demos on the website. Most of
them are by contributors.
Thank you.